I posted this on Instagram where the
cars are the maybach's in front of me
bouncing
right and then there's a Ferrari and the
Porsche and all the crazy cars all lined
up like this is Grand Theft Auto
this is Grand Theft Auto if I've ever
seen it we're on the beach in Malibu it
looks just like a video game so we take
off and this is when I'm like no no one
is with me this isn't real the little
kid in me is going are you [__] me
this is awesome there's so many cool
cars like this is so fun a couple
Porsches Lambos and [__] behind me in
front of me we're all like doing this
staying together and I'm supposed to
meet up with Franklin that night from
Grand Theft Auto supposed to meet up
with him that night because we're going
over some stuff he calls me in the
middle of this car run and I'm zipping
so I put him on speaker I have them on
speaker as I'm whipping through in the
hills and all these cars I just hear
what's up man what's up what's up Sean
you know no I'm just chilling I just
hear Michael's voice hey man
what so yeah I'm with her and he says
his real name he's like you know the you
know guy plays Michael because I was
supposed to meet with both of them but I
got back too late look at my rear view
nothing but Ferrari